[scurrying]
Well, I'm up.
It is 0 dark 30 and
the mice are just
freaking going to town, man.
Just [mouse sounds] just
all over the place, man.
They are just driving
me bat [bleep] crazy.
Oh!
God, they're just insane.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, the little bastards--
I wish I could stomp
their little guts in.
Oh, I was ready just--
I had to get up, man.
I was ready to
destroy my shelter--
I mean, just destroy it.
I was going to go off.
Oh.
Little bastard mice running
me out of my own bed.
I'm going to make a
fire, get my hands warm.
I'm just frustrated.
I'm tired.
I'm hungry and I'm
hungry and I'm hungry.
I'm hangry.
Little bastards!
God.
I have been dealing
with the mice
for up to a month now of
them waking me up and pitter
pattering around my shelter.
But now they're sleeping because
they like to party all night
and sleep all day.
You know, it's these little
things they don't-- they
don't tell you about.
They don't tell you about
the mice when you're--
when you go to survival school.
They just say,
just survive, man.
Just survive They didn't
tell me about the mice.
All right, well, I"m pulling
out all the stops today, boys.
Wake up, mice!
Wakey, wakey!
Wakey, wakey, mice!
You wake me up,
I'm waking you up.
You want a little bear spray?
I hope that it just filled their
little lungs with toxic fumes.
There.
That's that.
That's all of it,
you fricking things.
I should air horn them too.
[air horn]
That's fun.
Smells kind of peppery and
refreshing in my shelter.
A little pepper?
Is it a little peppery
in there for you, folks?